the movie begins with the narration
about the current situation of the earth
a boy named Joel Dawson says that his
life was normal until one day when a
huge asteroid named Agatha 616 was
heading straight to Earth Humanity
United and sent several Rockets into
space to combat the asteroid they
succeeded and the asteroid was destroyed
however the explosion also destroyed all
the Rockets causing its radioactive
elements to rain back to the Earth's
surface the chemical Fallout caused all
coldblooded animals such as frogs and
snails to mutate into large aggressive
monsters after that to be safe from the
mutated monsters people started Living
inside the safe places like underground
bunkers and caves with all openings
closed they started calling the place as
colonies 7 years later Joel now aged 24
lives in one of many underground bunkers
called colonies he always feels lonely
inside the bunker and says that his life
is not normal inside there the people
have started their own lifestyle which
is completely different from what it
used to be before the other survivors
except except for Joel have romantically
paired up with each other while fighting
monsters and Scavenging for supplies
inside the place they grow some
vegetables using the little light that
gets in they also tend to cow for their
necessary Dairy Supply and hunt for food
whenever they get out in the next Scene
It is revealed that during the
evacuation after the apocalypse a
teenage Joel was separated from his
girlfriend Amy but he promised to find
her Joel is assigned to work as a cck as
he is notorious for freezing in
dangerous situations and is considered a
liability as Joel is the only single guy
inside the colony he passes his time
doing target practice one day during his
practice he notices a rumbling sound
right above their bunker and alarms
everyone the team immediately decides to
exit and kill the monster but leave Joel
behind with some other people who can't
fight while the fighting team is out
others watch the movements on a monitor
and see one of the members getting
killed by the monster seeing this Joel
decides he's had enough and sets off
with just a crossbow to help his friends
there he notices a large creature in
front of him attacking his friend but
cannot move an inch in fear the creature
is about to attack Joel but luckily one
of the members arrives in time to kill
the monster and save him we are then
taken into the flashback from s years
ago when the asteroid was destroyed by
the help of rockets Joel is in his car
hanging out with his girlfriend Amy he
draws an awful picture of Amy despite
which she gifts him a box of colors as
they start to kiss and are about to get
intimate with each other an emergency
alarm goes off around the city the
remains of the Rockets fall back on the
Earth Earth creating great explosions
the two then drive back to their home
quickly where they see everyone packing
their bags to leave for the safe place
it's the day when the two hug each other
for the last time in the next scene we
see Joel Still drawing the monsters he
noticed in those seven years with the
same drawing tools Amy gifted him before
he also talks with Amy by the help of
the radio station he has during their
conversation the call gets disconnected
Midway due to a weak signal other team
members are seen warning over the death
of the team members Joel then has a
flashback of the day of the Apocalypse
where he and Amy embraced each other the
last time and comes up with a feeling of
uniting with her he expresses his
feelings to reunite with Amy in one of
the team meetings but everyone warns him
about the dangerous journey and also his
weakness in dangerous situations they
mention that Amy's colony is about 85 M
away and it will take him at least a
week to get there ignoring their
suggestions and warnings Joel decides to
reunite with his love and starts packing
his belongings reluctantly the other
survivors decide to help him out they
give him a map and a crossbow despite
their fear that he will not survive
after getting all his things ready Joel
heads out for the first time in 7 years
Joel is out in the sunlight breathing
fresh air he then takes out the map and
starts studying it before setting out on
his journey however he is unable to
determine the directions and heads
randomly passing through the suburbs he
finds some monster eggs but tries to
remain calm and moves forward later Joel
Hears A Sound and enters a nearby house
there he encounters a giant toad monster
who attacks him with its tongue making
him fall on the ground suddenly a dog
comes near Joel out of nowhere after
various attempts the toad catches Joel
by his leg and drags him towards its
mouth however the dog bites the tongue
of the toad and Joel is saved Joel then
follows the dog to a minivan where he
spends the night it seems to be the
dog's home Joel then sees boy written in
various places and assumes it to be the
dog's name next day Joel draws the
drawing of the dog in his notebook and
thanks him for saving his life Joel
resumes his journey but boy follows him
with his own 's blanket in his mouth
Joel keeps the blanket in his backpack
and with boy he walks towards his
destination on the way the two become
best friends and Joel tells him
everything about his life when Joel is
about to eat some poisonous berries boy
warns him against it and other dangers
on their way Joel falls into a nest of
worm monsters called sand gobblers he
tries to get out of it but fails despite
several attempts right then two
survivors Clyde Dutton and his adopted
daughter minnow arrive at the place and
rescue him with the help of a rope they
kill the remaining Monsters by tossing
explosives inside the hole after that
they introduced themselves and mentioned
that the two are heading north to the
mountains where the Colder Weather and
higher elevation means fewer monsters
Joel decides to follow them along with
boy until their path departs they teach
Joel some basic survival skills like how
to fight sense danger and find food
later while all of them are getting
along Clyde suddenly tells Joel not to
move as a monster is behind him he asks
Joel to take out his shirt but it takes
him some time because of his panic
attack then inserts Joel's shirt inside
the giant snail's shell telling that the
snail will now help them to be away from
another monster named chumbler minow
also shows Joel that not all monsters
are hostile demonstrating how one can
always tell from their eyes spending
some days together Clyde teaches him how
to look out for the monsters and minnow
assists him for his targeting skills the
pair invite Joel to stay with them but
Joel insists that he must find Amy his
teenage love as they part ways Clyde
gifts Joel with a grenade and suggests
to use it only when it is necessary as
Joel continues West boy seems terrified
as if he has sensed some danger boy
immediately hides under a boat and Joel
runs after him Joel then notices some
tentacles emerging out from the ground
and grabs his crossbow to attack the
monster centipede attacked by a giant
centipede monster Joel freezes and
remembers his parents getting crushed by
a giant monster's feet after having seen
losing his parents Joel now feels he
cannot lose boy after Gathering a lot of
Courage he eventually shoots the
centipede and kills it with his crossbow
saving boy at night it starts to rain
and they take shelter in an abandoned
Motel there they meet a damaged cbor
named Mavis Joel is aware about how to
use the robot as he had used them while
in the bunker before his battery dies
Mavis agrees to power Joel's radio long
enough to briefly contact Amy where he
learns that new survivors have reached
her Colony promising to lead them away
to safety as Mavis still has some power
left he sits outside with Joel listening
to his parents' story he then shows some
pictures of his parents and Joel gets
emotional seeing this with this sweet
moment Mavis battery dies and Joel sets
on to his journey to meet Amy the next
day Joel and boy are attacked by a
Queens sand gobler Clyde had warned him
about it being the most dangerous of the
all monsters while running away Joel
falls down but manages to take boy and
hides behind a tree trunk Joel also
shuts boy mouth as the creature is very
sensitive to sound thinking that there
is no one around the sand gobbler starts
to return back just then boy barks as he
sees the blanket of his previous owner
flying away giving away their position
the creature again chases them but Joel
manages to kill the queen with the
grenade and jumps into the river he then
yells at boy for putting their life in
danger after swimming across a river
Joel is covered in poisonous leeches and
starts to hallucinate from their venom
he swallows some leaves as an antidote
as suggested by Clyde out of nowhere Amy
appears there and Joel wakes to finally
see her Joel is extremely delighted to
meet Amy but is again unconscious
because of the poison from leeches he
regains his Consciousness inside Amy's
colony where she leads a beach colony of
elderly survivors who all depend on her
Joel is introduced to the new survivors
led by cap a former Royal Australian
Navy sailor who has managed to procure
an old yacht as everyone celebrates
their imminent departure Amy confesses
she is glad to see Joel but has no
romantic interest in him as she is still
mourning the death of someone close to
her hearing this from Amy a devastated
Joel realizes that Amy cannot love him
the way she used to before and decides
to return to his Colony Joel contacts
his previous Colony m members on the
radio learning that it has become unsafe
to stay there and that they two must
leave soon he takes out the map that his
team handed him and finds some sweet and
heartfelt messages written all over it
Joel then realizes that it is the team
where he truly belongs and decides to
head back to his Colony later Joel
notices something odd in the berries
served to him by cap he browses through
the drawings in his notebook and
confirms the berries to be poisonous he
then runs out to warn Amy realizing cap
is not to be trusted but gets knocked
out by a punch when he gains his
Consciousness he finds himself Amy and
the rest of her Colony tied up on the
beach cap reveals that he and his crew
are actually Pirates Who raid colonies
for food and fuel he says that his yacht
is towed to the place with the help of a
giant crab he summons a crab monster
rigged with a makeshift electric collar
to eat the colonists meanwhile Joel and
Amy Escape their Bonds in charge at the
Pirates boy returns and saves Amy who
steals a hand cannon from one of the
Pirates Joel is about to kill the crab
but he determines that the monster is
not not hostile by looking into its eyes
and instead uses the cannon to destroy
the electric collar which was
controlling it the crab leaves Joel
unharmed and sinks the yacht devouring
cap and the pirates in the next scene
Joel recommends Amy and her colony to
head north they share a romantic goodbye
kiss and Amy promises she will find him
Joel gives her a book containing all of
his survival knowledge and tracks all
the way back to his Colony when Joel
reaches home his Colony members are
extremely happy to see him back alive
Joel then persuades his members to head
towards the mountains as they are tired
of hiding Underground on the radio Joel
sends a message to other colonies
sharing his experiences so they will
also be ready to leave and meet back at
the surface as everyone heads North
Clyde and minnow already in the
mountains wonder if Joel